geht es donald trump wirklich so gut wie
er tut jedenfalls ist seine botschaft
klar fürchtet euch nicht vor dem virus
lasst nicht zu dass es euer leben
dominiert vielleicht liegt donald trump
sogar richtig wenn er zuversicht
verbreitet wenn auch mit den falschen
argumenten
niemand will diese krankheit haben aber
es werden sich absehbar noch
hunderttausende infizieren
keine angst vor corona hat donald damit
vielleicht recht wie halten wir es noch
monate vielleicht jahre aus in einem
risikogebiet namens deutschland wir
wollen reden mit diesen gästen ute
lemper die sängerin lebt seit vielen
jahren in new york und sah trump spielt
seinen anhängern einfach etwas vor
isabella eckerle für die virologin ist
klar herbst und winter werden sehr
anstrengend
helge braun der kanzleramtsminister
stellt fest das ist jetzt der klassische
beginn einer zweiten welle
julian nida rümelin der philosoph warnt
vor panik wir sollten nicht nur auf die
neuinfektionen schauen
patrick scheidt für den berliner
amtsarzt sind innerdeutsche
reisebeschränkungen vollkommen sinnlos
und malu dreyer
die ministerpräsidentin von rheinland
pfalz sagt wenn wir nicht mehr
nachverfolgen können dann müssen wir
wieder schließen
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
begrüßt die gäste heute abend sehr
herrlich herzlich und herrlich natürlich
auch zugeschaltet aus genf und aus
amerika und natürlich auch hier heute in
der runde
liebe zuschauer das virus schert sich
nicht um große namen mit donald trump
hatte sich aber wohl mit dem falschen
angelegt
das hat vor ihm nur einer geschafft
in drei tagen beweist trump was seine
jünger längst wissen
der messias ist unter uns und er hat
eine botschaft lasst euer leben nicht
von corona dominieren habt keine angst
davor
wir werden es besiegen trank hebt ab mit
trim dc wir steroiden plus antikörper
cocktail
nicht über den berg aber zurück im
weißen haus dem neuen corona hotspot für
die einen superman für die anderen
superstar hört auf euer herz und euer
gewissen und wer joe biden als ob es um
euer leben geht
ob trumps inszenierung als mutiger
bezwinger des virus auf geht bereits in
einer woche will er unbedingt wieder
persönlich gegen beiden antreten
vielleicht besser hinter panzerglas
vielleicht verschieben sie es aber auch
noch einstiegs runde hier bei uns helge
braun kanzleramtsminister
offensichtlich will donald trump
zuversicht ausstrahlen
die kanzlerin warnte zuletzt von 19.200
infektionen die wir dann kurz vor
weihnachten haben und macht also angst
was glauben sie wonach sehnen sich die
menschen mehr als es klüger
also ich glaube wir müssen den menschen
deutlich machen dass wir ganz klaren
plan haben wir gut durch die krise
kommen und ich glaube auch nicht dass
die kanzlerin angst macht und sagt
einmal vorgerechnet wenn die verdopplung
zeiten wie so mancher letzten zeit
hatten so weitergehen dann könnte es im
dezember zu so hohen zahlen kommen
aber das ist ja keine prognose sondern
genau das wollen wir verhindern und
deshalb hat sie auch in ihrer
haushaltsrede in der letzten woche noch
mal deutlich gesagt in diesem winter
müssen wir uns alle etwas mehr zusammen
nehmen als im sommer und dann haben wir
aber die chance wirklich gut durch die
krise zu kommen
bleiben wir noch mal bei amerika ich
begrüße in genf isabella eckerle sie ist
die leiterin des zentrums für neu
auftretende viruserkrankungen frau egger
lösen sagt donald trump er ist dank
eines antikörper medikamentes wieder
genesen
ferndiagnosen sind immer wahnsinnig
schwer aber erscheint das glaubwürdig in
ihren augen
also ich glaube zwei dinge die man
vorausschicken kann ist einmal
eine publikation die diese woche
erschienen ist die die verbreitung von
miss informationen also die info damage
also sozusagen die pandemie an miss
informationen untersucht hat und da drin
hat trump mit fast 40 prozent den
größten anteil sozusagen mit seinen
aussagen geliefert mit zweite ist ein
leitartikel politischer leitartikel der
im juli in den journal of medicine
erschienen ist also eine ganz
renommierte solide akademische
institution der usa
die erstmals in ihrer über 200-jährigen
geschichte eine politische stellungnahme
nimmt und ganz detailliert die das
versagen sozusagen der tramp regierung
darlegt dass nur um das meinen kontext
zu setzen wie sie sagen ferndiagnosen
sind immer schwer und aus medizinischer
sicht muss man sagen dass diese ganze
geschichte irgendwie hinten und vorne
nicht zusammen stimmt also ich verstehe
das gar nicht was was da jetzt
eigentlich passiert ist wann er sich
angesteckt hat ob er in woche eins ist
ob er in woche 2 ist das schwert
tatsächlich krank ist also normalerweise
ist ein patient nach so einem cocktail
an experimentellen therapie noch nicht
nach drei tagen wieder aus der klinik
entlassen also dass das passt irgendwie
alles nicht zusammen ob er jetzt schwer
krank war und im endeffekt zu dem
antikörper cocktail kann man nur sagen
dass man prinzipiell in der medizin nie
aus einzelfällen schlüsse auf die
wirksamkeit eines medikaments ziehen
kann und eben schon gar nicht wenn das
jetzt in kombination mit anderen
therapien erfolgt ist also er hat haben
wir bekommen und er hat auch erlangen
hier bekommen und auch cortison genommen
das könnte es also auch sein oder denken
sie es ist durchaus möglich dass er ein
wundermittel entdeckt hat also zu mdb
und dexamethason gibt es ja schon daten
und da wurde ja bereits gezeigt dass die
eben einen positiven effekt haben
allerdings in der zweiten
krankheitswoche bei eben einem
bestimmten patientenkollektiv die eben
schwerer erkrankt sind
das würde ja bei ihm jetzt nicht so
passen das wäre ja er jetzt noch an der
anfangsphase das sind die eher
kontraproduktiv ich glaube man kann es
im endeffekt nicht
also ist einfach es ist ein mix aus
verschiedenen therapien und man kann
daraus keine schlüsse ziehen es gibt
tatsächlich erste forschungsdaten gut
diesen zu diesem produkt oder zu diesem
medikament was positiv aussieht ich
denke auch dass die antikörpertherapie
durchaus vielversprechend sein könnte
aber ich glaube man kann jetzt nicht aus
dem einzelfall von donald trump
irgendwelche schlüsse auf eine
wirksamkeit ziehen so und damit sind wir
beim allgäuer der ministerpräsidentin
von rheinland pfalz jetzt sagt malu
dreyer
donald trump auch des virus darf nicht
unser leben dominieren könnte der gute
mann denn wenigstens mit dieser
botschaft mal richtig liegen naja
erstmal was frank macht das natürlich
brandgefährlich und es ist absolut
verantwortungslos er hat als staatsmann
wirklich die aufgabe das zu sagen worauf
eigentlich alle erfahrungen weltweit
beruht und ist nicht zu verharmlosen den
menschen nicht den eindruck zu
vermitteln
es gibt ein paar medikamente die
spendiere ich auch im ganzen volk und
damit ist alles gut ist es einfach nicht
die wahrheit nicht die realität und
damit ihre firmen und vor allem total
gefährlich wenn man schaut wieviele
menschen amerika gestorben sind an der
pandemie
inzwischen ist einfach wahnsinn was drum
gemacht ein ganz anderer punkt ist und
da will ich einfach ein brauner noch mal
recht geben keiner von uns sagt es macht
1 in den menschen angst zu machen im
gegenteil ich sage immer gehen müssen
eigenverantwortlich agieren die
allermeisten in der bevölkerung tun das
auch die muss man wirklich auch loben
und sich bedanken dafür weil wir
brauchen natürlich auch die zuversicht
dass wir als gesellschaft ist schaffen
wir können es auch schaffen und es
beides gehört zusammen ist realistisch
einzuschätzen zu sehen wo ist die gefahr
und gleichzeitig aber auch den
optimismus und zuversicht zu haben dass
wir es schaffen können weil die
bevölkerung insgesamt doch auch sehr
verlässlich ist und verlässlich mitmacht
bei uns ist julian nida-rümelin bekannt
fehlen noch als kultur-staatsminister
der sie waren sie sind und bleiben
philosoph darf ein politiker handy
darüber liegen übertreiben für einen
guten zweck
also ich bin der meinung dass die
demokratie von wahrhaftigkeit und
wahrheit lebt hat man 2006 ein ganzes
buch darüber geschrieben demokratie und
wahrheit haben die leute gesagt was und
wer bei einer politik und glaubt
ernsthaft in
die geht es um wahrhaftigkeit und
wahrheit so unterdessen sagen manche na
ja vielleicht doch wenigstens im
spurenelementen sollte seine rolle
spielen und dass wir da haben ist die
reihen form eines politikers der
offenbar nicht nur parteiinteressen das
interessierte nämlich auch nicht sondern
seine ganz persönlichen interessen
strategische kommunikation auf dieser
grundlage praktiziert und das ergebnis
ist ein umfassender vertrauensverlust
einerseits und eine fast gläubige
anhängerschaft die einfach alles abnimmt
dass ihr vormann da von sich gibt und
das geht an die wurzeln der demokratie
bei uns ist patrick langscheid sie sind
arzt erscheint und leiten
in reinickendorf berlin berlin
reinickendorf einen gesundheitsamt mal
frage an den fachmann dürfte donald
trump eigentlich jetzt schon aus der
quarantäne
keiner von uns weiß wie krank er war ob
er krank war was eigentlich wirklich ist
die kollegin hat es immer scans ja sehr
deutlich gesagt in deutschland wurde er
mit den geltenden rechts regelungen
kollidieren
ich fürchte allerdings das ist ihr auch
nicht sonderlich stören würde
also das ist ihm nicht sonderlich viele
sicherlich wir fragen wir mal ganz
schnell nach bei mrt sind der uns aus
dem washington zugeschaltet ist und
dafür danken wir elmar nachricht des
tages war dass donald trump ein
virtuelles duell mit joe biden nicht
akzeptieren wird jetzt haben sich
offensichtlich beide seiten darauf
verständigt es zu vertagen zu verlegen
wie geht es jetzt weiter glauben sie ja
es geht noch hin und her es ist noch
nicht ganz klar ob das zweite duell
daneben verschoben ist um eine woche und
gar kein drittes dann stattfindet das
beiden team bildern kein drittes
tv-duell mehr donald trump besteht
darauf am 29 oktober also ganz kurz vor
der wahl
ausgang offen also fest steht hier das
der präsident ganz offenbar jetzt in
einer art defensivhaltung ist es deutet
vieles darauf hin dass er mit seinem
verhalten in den letzten zwei wochen ja
im grunde genommen noch mehr an
zustimmung verloren hat die umfrage
weiter sind sehr klar in einigen
wichtigen bundesstaaten liegt er
deutlich hinten
landesweit 15 prozentpunkte hinten und
das hat sicherlich damit zu tun dass er
nach außen hin zwar so tut als hätte er
das thema corona im griff aber wenn
gleichzeitig im weißen haus 34 personen
positiv getestet sind wenn mehrere davon
krank sind einer auch sehr schwer krank
ist wie ist wie wir hören das ist der
sicherheitschef im weißen haus wenn der
halbe generalstab positiv getestet wurde
ich glaube da sagen auch viele
amerikaner und das sehen wir in den
umfragen eben das kann nicht stimmen was
donald trump behauptet nun feiert der
präsident und inszeniert seine gesundung
als eine art auferstehung ist das
wirklich typisch tram oder ist es nicht
auch ein bisschen typisch amerika also
hat es natürlich immer schon gegeben
ronald reagan war im brunnen der erste
große meister darin der genau zur besten
sendezeit abends mit dem hubschrauber
hinter den weißen haus gelandet ist
sogar vor dem kapitol damit er dann auf
diese weise durch die bilder in die
abendnachrichten kam da war eigentlich
der text der darauf gesprochen wurde
nebensache hier ist es ein stück weiter
gehend donald trump inszeniert sich so
um falschinformationen zu verbreiten
nicht einfach nur um einen eindruck zu
erzeugen das sagen alle medizinischen
beobachter das sagen auch viele kritiker
innerhalb seiner eigenen partei
er verbreitet damit falschinformationen
erweckt den eindruck als wäre diese
erkrankung so eine art jungbrunnen so
hat das ja raus gewitter der fühle sich
wie vor 20 jahren zuletzt so frisch und
damit das sagen auch manche sehr klar
hat das fast etwas von einem art von
einer acht todeskult also im grunde
genommen seine anhänger aufzufordern sie
sollten noch bewusst das risiko eingehen
möglicherweise um herdenimmunität zu
erzeugen aber der preis dafür kann
extrem hoch sein wie wir an den 210 1000
toten in den usa sehen
und damit haben sie eigentlich auch
schon beantwortet die frage nämlich ob
es ihnen jetzt politisch nutzt im
wahlkampf eher nein
also ich glaube es nutzt ihn nicht erst
zwei mal falsch abgebogen in den letzten
anderthalb wochen kann man sagen einmal
bei der debatte in der sehr
unzivilisiert er sich verhalten hat dann
joe biden auch ein stück weit aber vor
allen dingen donald trump
hat er die chance verpasst die
wirtschaft zu dem großen thema im
wahlkampf zu machen
nur in diesem bereich kann er punkten
umfragen sagen da trauen ihm die
amerikaner mehr zu als show beiden und
der zweite große fehler eben dann als er
krank war diese krankheit für propaganda
zu brauchen zu missbrauchen
zu behaupten dass diese
behandlungsmethode jedem amerikaner zur
verfügung steht das ist nicht so dass
steht dem präsidenten zur verfügung
nicht jedem amerikaner und deswegen
gerade die opfer oder auch die
angehörigen der opfer haben sich zu wort
gemeldet in den letzten tagen und klar
gemacht das ist ein zynisches spiel und
ich glaube das schlägt sich in den
umfragewerten nieder
also joe biden hat seinen vorsprung noch
einmal deutlich vergrößert danke immer
danke nach washington und wir sind
zurück in der runde mit der klassischen
frage herr braun
sie sind arzt und politiker muss der
leibarzt von sonnenschein konnte muss er
die volle wahrheit über die gesundheit
des präsidenten zeigen
grundsätzlich gibt es eigentlich
natürlich auch gerade bei so sensiblen
daten wie gesundheit eine privatsphäre
für einen präsidenten aber er hebt die
ja selber auf indem wir das quasi so zur
populistischen thema macht er im grunde
genommen kann man sich nur wünschen dass
personen die in der öffentlichkeit
stehen uns vorleben wie man richtig
damit umgeht wir rufen hier jeden tag
auf und sagen wir positiv getestet es
muss in quarantäne gehen wir müssen
aufpassen dass sich das virus nicht
verbreitet und als das ausmaß an
verbreitung im weißen haus das ist
wirklich zeigt dass dort das virus nicht
ernst genommen wird und das ist
natürlich ein verheerendes seine gesamte
bevölkerung und trotzdem die frage herr
nida rümelin er kann man einen
us-präsidenten behandeln wie jeden
anderen normalen präsidenten also wenn
donald trump schnupfen hat dann meldet
das sofort die börse und die
börsenmärkte es auch sofort das ist das
problem im grunde weiß die ganze welt
und ersetzen was von ihm als person zu
halten ist und trotzdem fasziniert
blickt die gesamte welt auf diese
ausfälle die eine oder andere richtung
ich meine ich persönlich hoffe dass er
spuckt demnächst vorbei ist aber man
weiß es natürlich nicht und was mich
wirklich besorgt ist dass das schule
macht deren brasilien ist schon der name
gefallen ball so nahe wo wir haben auch
in europa so nachahmer versuche in
italien ist das im vergangenen august
gerade noch gescheitert sei weniger
ziemlich genauso aufgeführt
ungarn ist auch so eine art kleiner
vorläufer sogar also dass erodiert und
deswegen muss man sich wegen trump da
wird sie nichts mehr ändern aber die
demokratie muss sich stabilisieren das
zum thema so und bei ihnen frau 3er ist
es im grunde genommen auch eine frage
wie sehr ist die krankheit eines
präsidenten wie sehr ist auch die
krankheit einer ministerpräsidentin
privatsache wie ehrlich kann man und
muss man in so eine situation sein also
in deutschland haben wir glaube ich
schon eine große offenheit man sieht ja
wenn ich an herrn schäuble denke
bundestagspräsident manuela schwesig
eine krebserkrankung überstanden hat ich
selber mit einer chronischen erkrankung
also wir können wirklich auch öffentlich
darüber sprechen und gleichzeitig ist es
so dass wir in deutschland natürlich
auch immer ein stück privatsphäre haben
nicht alles muss öffentlich gemacht
werden das verlangt auch niemand aber
ich glaube schon man muss sehr
verantwortungsvoll mit der frage oben
gehen fühlt man sich selbst in der lage
auch gesundheitlich so ein amt
beispielsweise zu durchleiden ich glaube
darauf als die öffentlichkeit schon ein
anrecht aber ansonsten gibt es natürlich
auch einen geschützten raum aber ich
glaube hier eine gute beispiele in
deutschland die zeigen man kann mit
krankheit auch in der öffentlichkeit
umgehen und es tatsächlich auch eine
transparenz schaffen
wir fragen noch mal nach new york wie es
sich in dieser stadt jetzt eigentlich
anfühlt mit corona zu sein und zu leben
und begrüßen ganz herzlich und lemper
die uns wie skype zugeschaltet ist voll
aber sie glauben auch nicht an die
spontanheilung von donald trump
es ist eine unglaubliche fahrt wir
können das hier gar nicht glauben man
hätte ihn ja fast gewünscht dass er nun
wirklich mal ordentlich krank wird er
hat ja mit dem teufel gespielt sozusagen
und demonstrativ sich als invincible als
unbesiegbar erklärt es geht eben nur um
die starke die er repräsentiert die
amerika repräsentiert und diese sieht er
reflektiert nur in der wirtschaft ja
also der stark das monster amerika soll
eben die welt in monaten und
kooperationen und allem was dazugehört
regieren und leider hat er etliche
fehler informiert
das ist furchtbar eigentlich auch
gefährlich ich stimme ihnen das total zu
und es tut mir furchtbar leid die
menschen die ihre angehörigen verloren
haben
die sich eine 50.000 dollar behandlung
nicht leisten können wie er damit trotz
angeblich geheilt geworden zu sein aber
ich denke er sei trotzdem irgendwie
atemlos aus in seinen beiträgen und wie
er sich dann pompös die maske abgerissen
hat ist doch fast unfassbar
schauen wir uns new york an wir hatten
hier das epizentrum im april und dann
haben die new yorker sich wahnsinnig
dran gehalten die die die regeln der
regeln zu folgen das heißt also maske
auf die kinder haben die maske auf in
den straßen auf dem fahrrad trägt man
sie sogar die jogger tragen die maske
natürlich in deining ist zu und der
sommer hat sich unglaublich hier getan
in new york die infektionsraten sind
ganz niedrig und schauen wir uns an was
in den südstaaten passiert ist im
südviertel in der schattenwelt wo die
menschen sich korrigiert haben wo sie
verrückt mit miteinander ohne maske in
den straßen sich versammelt haben oder
auf den paar tage politischen
veranstaltungen darunter sind die in
hoch geschossen
es ist doch alles nur wissenschaft
jetzt in new york gerade geht's wieder
los und zwar ein wirklich und in queens
und zwar dort in den williams burg in
den orthodoxen nachbarschaften wo viele
also jährige mitbewohner einfach diese
regel nicht beachten und jetzt geht's
wieder los hier also nicht in meine
nerven sondern vor allen dingen brooklyn
und jetzt werden die schulen wieder
geschlossen in diesen stadtteilen und
das ganze ist wissen und das ist
tatsächlich verheerend wie schützen sie
sich und ihre familie frau lemper was
tun sie meine kinder haben nur ein zwei
tage schule in der woche der rest ist
zuhause remote wir müssen also mit den
kindern die schulaufgaben machen und die
kinder tragen masken tragen masken
draußen aber ansonsten also es halten
sich auch nicht alle daran die kinder
reißen sich die masken ab sobald die
schule verweisen gehen auf die
spielplätze und wollen spielen und
kontakt haben also so einfach ist die
sache nicht
aber wir halten uns einfach an die
regeln machen interessant ihre wichtige
frage ist natürlich auch wovor die
menschen mehr sorge haben haben sie mehr
sorge von corona oder haben sie mehr
sorgen davor ihre jobs zu verlieren
sie selber können sich helfen sie machen
an tollen live streamen ende oktober 25
aber haben die menschen mehr angst vor
diesem virus oder sorgen sie sich mehr
um die jobs hat es sind zwei krankheiten
die akkus sind und die armut die jetzt
eingetreten ist
durch die arbeitslosigkeit durch diese
tausende von restaurants die zugemacht
haben in new york in die ganze
kulturszene 1 war ein antrieb der
wirtschaft gewesen
broadway und die theater carnegie hall
metropolitan opera
all diese institutionen sind geschlossen
es ist wirklich sehr sehr traurig in die
arbeitslosigkeit wie eingetreten ist als
eine wirklich eine schlimme welle und es
trifft eben die die armen am meisten die
wirklich auf ihre kleinen betriebe
angewiesen angewiesen worden sind und
von monat zu monat gelebt haben mit
ihrem check aldi das ist an eine
blutkrankheit die jetzt eingetreten ist
mit mit der arbeitslosigkeit
wir wissen dass ich bin ja sie haben
alle ihre jobs verloren und das ist
tatsächlich wahrscheinlich in der stadt
auch ein furchtbares bild wenn man an
den geschlossenen leben vorbei läuft
haben sie in den letzten monaten schon
mal darüber nachgedacht wieder zurück
nach deutschland zu kommen
da denke ich eigentlich stetig so war
nach also ich bin als war new yorkerin
aber keine amerikanerin dem herzen da
habe ich mich nie mit dieser künstler
untereinander setzen können aber ich bin
gerne new yorkerin war hier doch eine
unglaubliche progressive multikulturelle
offene kultur existiert die einfach
einen schritt weiter ist als damen
einmal eine nationale kultur die einfach
ein schritt weiter reicht an toleranz an
auch an kreativität und an abenteuerlich
leiden und also bleiben sie in new york
und bleiben europäerinnen und wir
drücken die daumen und wünschen viel
glück vielen vielen dank für dieses
gespräch zu ihnen herr laschheit
entscheidet tatsächlich die tödlich kite
eines virus ist am ende auch oder wie
tödlichen virus ist entscheidend mit wie
gesund eine bevölkerung ist und wie ein
gesundheitssystem ausgestattet ist ist
dass am ende auch wichtig also diese
abhängigkeit
ist im moment gar nicht das thema womit
wir uns vordringlich beschäftigen
sondern im moment wollen wir auf dem weg
weitermachen dass die frage der tödlich
kite für ganz wenige überhaupt relevant
wird wir haben ja im moment die paradoxe
situation dass wir durch unsere
bemühungen die pandemie im vergleich zu
den uns umgebenden europäischen ländern
ja immer noch auf ein erträgliches maß
reduzieren konnten
wir sehen weniger tödliche verläufe zur
zeit und es gibt gleichzeitig den
vorwurf dass es dann ja wohl nicht so
schlimm sein kann aber es ist nicht so
schlimm weil wir etwas dafür tun dass
heißt nicht so berühmte paradoxon
nun haben wir die zahlen von heute
natürlich alle in den poren sie liegt
bei vierter über 4000 am heutigen tag
gemessen die neuinfektionen immer
mehr menschen infizieren sich aber immer
weniger erkranken schwer wird das so
bleiben ist die große frage sie sind
jung sie feiern
sie verbreiten dass corona virus ob
private partys oder voller bars und
kneipen die behörden haben immer stärker
die sogenannten super special events im
visier
doch in den allermeisten fällen verläuft
gewidmet oder asymptomatisch bei den
jüngeren mitte april kamen noch 22
prozent der infizierten ins krankenhaus
heute sind es nur noch fünf in der 16
kalenderwoche starben sieben prozent der
positiv getesteten mit oder an cupid 19
aktuell liegt die sterberate zwischen
0,1 und 0,4 prozent kein biologe würde
widersprechen dass wir alle damit
rechnen dass sich die infektionszahlen
anders entwickeln nämlich massiv nach
oben gehen werden
20.000 neuinfektionen pro tag das klingt
erstmal nach apokalypse
das sind enorme zahlen aber im grunde
sollte uns das keine angst machen weil
ein milder verlauf oder ein verlauf ohne
symptome trägt nicht so stark zum
infektionsgeschehen
[Musik]
in deutschland sterben auch ohne corona
durchschnittlich an die 20.000 menschen
pro woche nur mit der april gab es eine
leichte über sterblichkeit durch ko witt
der ausreißer im august geht auf die
hitzewelle zurück die absolute zahl der
korona toten pro woche liegt seit
monaten im niedrigen zweistelligen
bereich
herr braun noch mal das zitat der
kanzlerin exponentielles wachstum 19.200
an weihnachten wäre das wirklich die
apokalypse und hendrik strikt zu
zitieren
ja weil er muss her deutlich geworden
dass was wir erreichen müssen das dass
wir die kontakte vollständig
nachvollziehen
dann bleiben die infektionszahlen
niedrig und das sieht man momentan in
einigen hotspots gelingt uns das nicht
mehr steigt plötzlich die infektions
zeit sehr sehr schnell an und dann ist
es nur eine frage von wochen dass wir
auch eine anzahl an infektionen haben
die dann das gesundheitswesen stark
belasten wo der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst überhaupt nicht mehr
mitkommt und wo die zahl der
krankenhauseinweisungen toten wieder
deutlich steigt und dann ist ja die
frage haben wir dann noch ein mittel in
der hand und das mittel lautet dann
irgendwie nur noch lockdown und da wird
den genau verhindern wollen bleibt
einfach der maßstab für unser handeln
eine so niedrige infektionsrate zu haben
dass wir die kontakte wirklich
nachvollziehen
und wir haben es jetzt gerade aus den
usa gilt überall wo die infektionszahlen
hoch sind eher in frankreich sehen wir
dass gerade in spanien in den usa
das macht auch massive wirtschaftliche
probleme
während die länder die extrem gut sind
die zahlen unten zu halten neuseeland
südkorea oder china haben teilweise
jetzt sogar positives wachstum in diesem
jahr also man kann auch im blick aufs
ausland zeigen niedrige infektionszahlen
sind auch das beste für die wirtschaft
und es führt dazu dass wir am ende nicht
so viele tote zu beklagen haben
da gibt es für mich gar keine frage da
gibt es keine frage es ist interessant
viele schauen aber auf die schwerst
erkrankten hernieder übernehmen und auf
die todeszahlen schwerst erkrankt sind
momentan 487 menschen also auf
intensivstationen und 239 davon wäre
beatmet ist es also richtig auch auf
diese zahlen zu schauen oder wollen sie
einfach nur die zeit abwarten bis dann
die krankenhäuser wieder voll sind
also wir haben vorher von wahrhaftigkeit
gesprochen also ganz schlimm ist es wenn
risiken nach parteipolitischen
präferenzen beurteilt werden man muss
wirklich die daten anschauen und sich
ein bild machen und das bild ist sehr
sehr komplex natürlich sind die
registrierten infizierten deswegen habe
ich an einer stelle ihre sehr schönen
darstellung den kopf geschüttelt aber im
april die rede davon wie hoch der
prozentsatz war wir wissen den
prozentsatz nicht weil wir nicht wissen
wie viele im april infiziert waren
mit verlaub das waren möglicherweise
sieben mal so viele wie registrierte
waren das erklärt auch einige anomalien
und tatsächlich ist es somit 19 ist
extrem extrem fokussiert ganz anders als
die spanische grippe das hat die
mittlere generation vor allem getroffen
millionen von menschen weltweit die
wahrscheinlichkeit zu versterben ist
nach einer jüngst vor gelegenen
metastudie die sehr viele andere studien
ausgewertet haben bei den menschen unter
da eine zahl ich weiß mehr
öffentlichkeit darf man nicht über
zahlen reden 0 war um 0 03 prozent
und es gibt eine enge korrelation
zwischen bestimmten vorerkrankungen und
den todesfällen die todesfälle sind der
schlimmste schwer krank werden ist auch
schon schlimm genug auf intensivbetten
kommen da sind die drei stufen
gewissermaßen darauf müssen wir schauen
und jetzt kommt die entscheidende frage
und da muss man wirklich sich genau
langfristig überlegen wir mit umgehen je
nachdem wie sich das jetzt
weiterentwickelt die registrierten
infizierten sind ein indikator ein
wichtiger eckert was wir gegenwärtig
erleben ist dass sich das
durchschnittsalter der infektionen der
neuinfizierten nach unten verlagert und
wie es ist kann gar nicht anders sein
das wusste man schon im märz es kann gar
nicht anders sein dass dann der
prozentsatz derjenigen die schwer krank
werden oder gar sterben dramatisch
sinken muss dramatisch senken
so jetzt die berechtigte gefahr ist dass
das so nicht bleibt unter das thema
innovationen wieder hoch ja und da bin
ich nun der meinung es ist übrigens ganz
merkwürdig jetzt am vierten oktober ist
die great barrington nicht barrier reef
wie manche taucher mainzer great
barrington declaration
von stanford oxford und harvard
epidemiologen die haben natürlich meine
texte nicht gelesen aber es ist wörtlich
das drin was ich für richtig halte
und die sagen da bin ich ein bisschen
anderer meinung jetzt schon müssen einen
strategiewechsel vollziehen jetzt schon
sollten wir fokussieren wir haben auf
lokale risiken wert gelegt jetzt das ist
sehr gut gelaufen
gott sei dank wir haben nicht mehr
flächendeckend sein lokal und jetzt
müssen wir schauen wer ist wirklich
betroffen wer ist gefährdet bei den
unter 30 jährigen spricht sich deshalb
langsam herum
ja sie persönlich nicht gefährdet sind
oder fast nicht gefährdet es gut gehen
wir die frage noch mal weiter ein
trauriger dede hier in der runde
diskutiert frau eckerle können auch die
infizierten zahlen steigen und die
zahlen der schwerst erkrankten und der
toten eben nicht prozentual na ja also
ich glaube dass es da auch noch mal
wichtig ist dass man einfach ins ausland
guckt weil man kann sagen das virus hat
sich nicht verändert wir haben in
deutschland und in der schweiz kein
anderes virus als in den anderen ländern
und wir sind auch von unserer
biologischen grundausstattung nicht
anders als menschen in anderen ländern
und mir fehlt da manchmal der blick über
die ländergrenzen natürlich haben wir
jetzt diesen schnappschuss von von der
aktuellen situation wo das virus vor
allem unter jungen zirkuliert was ich
nicht stark in hospitalisierung oder in
todesfällen niederschlägt aber wir haben
wir können das in ganz ganz vielen
ländern dieses szenario durchspielen wir
sind einfach noch etwas früher als die
anderen länder
das virus ist überall in der bevölkerung
und es dringt eben auch in die älteren
gruppen vor und je höher die inzidenz
steigt desto schwieriger wird auch
risikopersonen abzuschirmen und zu den
risikopersonen würde ich gerne noch
etwas sagen
man spricht oft darüber als wären das
jetzt wirklich nur hochbetagten über 80
jährige und dem ist nicht so also es
gibt auch junge patienten die
risikopatienten sind patienten mit
vorerkrankungen schwangere frauen zum
beispiel sind gelten als eine
risikogruppe und für bisschen aktive
mitglieder der gesellschaft als es geht
nicht nur darum dass man jetzt ältere
leute im altersheim abschirmt das ist
meines erachtens sehr sehr schwer
vorauszusagen wie haben risiko hat also
man hat auch junge patienten auf
intensivstationen schwer krank sind die
auch versterben
und je mehr infektionsfälle wir
insgesamt haben
mehr werden wir auch von diesen jungen
fällen sehen die frage ist eben wollen
wollen wir nach diesen fall zahlen gehen
die wir in der klinik sehen weil wir
wissen eben wenn wir die neuinfektionen
anschauen dann blicken wir eine woche in
die vergangenheit zurück wenn wir die
hospitalisierung anschauen vielleicht
zwei wochen wenn wir die intensiv zahlen
nehmen dann blicken wir drei vier fünf
vielleicht sogar sechs wochen zurück
weil einfach der krankheitsverlauf so
krank so lange ist und das heißt wenn
ich nach den intensiv zahlen cook und
dann maßnahmen treffen dann treffe ich
die maßnahmen die ich eigentlich verein
wohnen länger treffen müssen ok und
trotzdem genauer die das sagt glaube ich
wichtig dass wir schauen immer in die
vergangenheit wir können nicht an die
zuschauer zukunft schauen mit diesen
falls und trotzdem noch mal die frage
gibt es nicht auch aus der wissenschaft
gute gründe optimistisch zu sein einfach
auch weil auf den intensivstationen
jetzt anders behandelt wird weil wir
mehr wissen weil die menschen heute auf
einer intensivstation eben andere
medikamente bekommen gibt es nicht auch
da gute gründe zu hoffen man muss sich
sorgen machen um die ausbreitung aber
vielleicht nicht so sehr um die
erkrankten also das kann man mit ja nein
beantworten ich denke es gibt auch es
gibt viel und hoffnungsvoll zu sein
das betrifft die therapie wir haben ja
schon dass rim dezidiertes dexamethason
erwähnt wir sehen dass bei dieser
patientengruppe bei denen diese therapie
indiziert ist dass es den tatsächlich
viel besser geht mit dieser therapie
aber man darf nicht vergessen dass das
trotzdem schon patienten sind die
relativ schwer erkrankt sind also die
müssen in die klinik die können nicht
mehr ohne sauerstoffzufuhr richtig atmen
und das primäre ziel muss natürlich sein
diese patienten erstmal zu vermeiden und
das zweite was eben auch oft vergessen
wird auch wenn wir noch genug
intensivbetten haben in dem moment wo
jemand auf einer intensivstation landet
ist ja auch schwer krank er hat ein
hohes risiko für komplikationen sich
nicht wieder gut zu erholen
ein aspekt den man eben auch komplett
jetzt noch nicht erwähnt hat ist eben
auch die belastung für das
gesundheitssystem aber auch für das
personal das eben mit diesen patienten
umgehen muss genau und ich glaube
natürlich eine ganz große
gute nachricht oder eine hoffnung ist
natürlich der impfstoff und da wurden ja
auch schon viele vorläufige daten
gezeigt oder es sind viele studien im
gange die dies sehr aussichtsreich
erscheinen lassen dass es einen
impfstoff kandidat haben werden der der
uns helfen wird diese pandemie zu
sprechen